all right welcome to another episode of
left to be talked the [ __ ] in files and
it is uh 230 on a Tuesday live in
concert spicer and I are here at the All
Things comedy studio how everybody I'm
great dude in the beautiful all things
comics to do how are you your black on
black on black yeah yeah well I woke up
early this morning and it was kind of
cold it was yeah yeah you know it was
like in the 50s and I was right now to
Margaret Cho's house too interviewer
this morning so I was bundled up in the
jacket and stuff and I was glad I did
stepped out of the house for a minute
but just like a flan I was like ah now
it's cold yeah were you out yesterday
there's like a wind storm was like a
death 20-minute er well right I got huge
rain like out east right I was like
pouring and like the wind was whipping
around and in like 20 minutes later it
was sunny again I was just like what the
[ __ ] has to rain tomorrow is it yeah
that's what they say crazy yeah that
wind yesterday insane just out of
nowhere yeah so funny i went to lunch
with a buddy I road there just in studio
city yeah killer day out yeah come out
of a lunch an hour later just [ __ ]
crazy hurricane with him I'm going down
Ventura Boulevard eyeball like what is
this gonna get a bike with a sidecar
just to keep you planted in the wind by
the time I got home though it was like
over yeah oh man so [ __ ] weird how
something like that could blow in just
out of nowhere yeah it was it was weird
la whether you guys saying I said in my
podcast and everybody tweeted of it wind
wind is just a dick yeah nobody likes
the wind yeah nobody ever I never hear
anybody go you know I need a beautiful
windy day no you want to breathe yeah no
one wants a full-blown wind wind sucks
yeah when sucks anyway uh we're back
from la jolla we had a great weekend out
there maha Comedy Store and it was I
said it on my podcast Monday but it felt
like the first shows really where you
know a lot of people are coming out from
podcast and and and just tweets and
stuff so it was felt good the rooms were
full yeah also to say on this record
which I've said publicly many times
before Dean you're the best dude ah I
think I might be joking but one the week
was incredible thank you for taking me
down there okay great time and then also
you're not even there and another buddy
has the best weekend of his [ __ ] life
because of you as well and those are
just two examples oh yeah last of this
past weekend like everybody knows you
work hard and you're great comic and you
know rock and bikes and all this [ __ ]
but when push comes to shove like you're
the reason that people aren't afraid of
dudes with tattoos anymore because
you're just the nicest [ __ ] guy I
want dad I'm sorry it's a [ __ ] if the
label you wear on the back on your back
in Old English it just says nice what a
great weekend though um well first of
all I've been planning to sell my CDs
and and if you're listening to this
episode I really want to target on this
a little bit I have no CD player I
haven't had a CD player in about six
years when the one broke inside my mac
apple macbook you know the original idea
of me of course early on was collect all
the CDs I could after vinyl love them
and and they were easy to store and and
and all that but over the last six years
I have not listened to a CD because I
was slowly I had that old thought of
mind of like and most people did until
streaming came around of well I'm not
just going to buy it on iTunes because I
want to own it which is true you want to
own something in case itunes crashes or
whatever and you lost all your [ __ ] you
bought on itunes right so or later on I
remember Rose attack saying that cloud
computing is [ __ ] because what will
happen is you'll put all your [ __ ] up in
the cloud and then now they'll trap you
a lot like cellphones did we
they realize you need data and they'll
slowly raise the price for storage sure
which is an amazing thing coming from
Steve was an act so my idea was always
owned it sorry buy the CD rip it put it
into itunes then put it up into my
shelves you've been to my house yeah
just hundreds and hundreds of shelves
and then they SAT there for years and I
realized as I moved I over a couple
thousand CDs yeah and a lot of them I
enjoyed looking at him sure more than
anything cuz I was like I [ __ ] forgot
about this band like Rooney yeah pulled
out Rooney or the stills or jet all
these bands i call him Coachella
purchases after Coachella you run home
he got up it was great hey probably
maybe don't listen to it every gave me
you put it on and you're like this [ __ ]
is pretty good yeah anyways I got all
those cds and my plan was to sell them I
went to amoeba and they said yeah about
a quarter to fifty cents apiece yeah and
DVD is 50 cent DVDs really make me
pissed off cuz those things are like 30
[ __ ] bucks never no one wants up and
no one wants him and they were given a
dollar maybe on some fifty cents on a
DVD where they where the music still
kind of worth something to him fifty
cents yeah but you may be only about it
for ten so I shopped around uh I
happened to be in san diego as this
record store what do you give and he
said anywhere from a dollar to five
dollars I was like dollar 25 so I boxed
up my seat in CDs and they've been in
the living room just there like bad
furniture for about four months plotting
plotting this drive down you and I to do
the shows and bring them in the day
comes you show up we pack your ride we
fill your Prius I have a I have a
regular prius not the brand new one like
whatever you most people know what a
prius looks like and i have two kids so
i usually have car seats in there I was
like yeah no worries I'll take the car
seats out it'll be easy I get there and
I'm like [ __ ] dude I mean
we made it fit but it wasn't easy no we
left two boxes huh remember because I
was just like oh [ __ ] it and I forgot we
left two boxes home until I got home as
I oh well I actually have five boxes of
CDs so we bring him down there and we
bring him to the guy yeah and he says
you got to leave these for a couple days
there's no way I can go through them and
I mean there's a couple thousand yeah
and and this is straight on the honor
program with this guy because I'm not
sitting there watching him as you
usually go with like 50 stack them in
frontier real quick on these or corner
those are eighty cents and don't
whatever right we leave them we go to
shows he calls me saturday afternoon
says okay I gotta check for a thousand
dollars for it yes like all right on man
and I show up and he goes and I didn't
take those three boxes I'm like wait a
minute I got a thousand dollars and
three boxes still so it was a great
weekend and I just don't use CDs and you
don't either we stream yeah and it's to
me the life of a 999 streaming each
month over a like if you just buy one CD
a month right you've already paid for
the streaming you know and I always grab
people like well oh you know either buy
vinyl or stream sure you know what to me
vinyl us we talk about this this weekend
like vinyl to me is like a Craftsman
home like an old Spanish house like the
album's look dope when they came out
they were works of art people were
framing records in their house you know
when the first record came out it holds
up so as a thing to display yeah it
looks beautiful people have loved the
sound of them since the day of release
people have loved the idea of it's hard
to skip so you're listening to a record
as an experience like all this stuff has
rock around I'll finish that yeah yeah
let's grab the call hey what's going on
you're on the air who's this it is chris
from New York what's going on dude amen
I'm back taking a call so yeah we can
talk about CDs and ear use of you know
downloading all
thats I just wanted to kind of chime in
if that's already absolutely dude
absolutely do you buy CDs hearing there
yeah I came to the conclusion that I
like CDs for certain types of music
because with LPS if you have like
classic records like Ramones certain
subterranean jungle right there be a
laughing sounding record so you have to
buy that weight on to put onto LT to
give it two more base and if you kind of
put the CD in a car you know it'll
really really click you know yeah I'm
them in as far as the box of cds it's
funny because when i was in high school
somebody must have died because i was at
a friend's place and we went outside and
it was the original Beastie Boys like
Kenyan shins hola like Bauhaus original
and I can go on and on it was in that
vein of really good stuff and that's how
I discovered you know love of LPS before
it became fashionable now right I I
think that a lot of people get into that
addiction of I need it remastered and
booming and to me if you grew up the
first wave with the records they just
sound normal to me yeah I mean I don't
roll over go this needs way more bass
because to me that's how the band
decided to put it out maybe they ran out
of money while they're mixing or
mastering and that's the beauty of that
project you know what I mean and the
soul of it I always hate when bands go
and remaster [ __ ] unless it was like a
really bad low volume thing you know
where you got turn your [ __ ] up on like
eight but I like when the record just
sounds like it did like those beetles
mono are worth a lot of money because
they sound so [ __ ] cool and weird you
know mm-hmm I think it made it onto than
to see the band live because you'd like
even like Beastie Boys where all of
their [ __ ] I thought sounded fantastic
as released but it still sounds so
different the few times I saw
live in your clothes and those speakers
are just like blaring in your face every
time they hit a hit a bass drop or
whatever and you're just like yeah I can
throw my CDs away I can never listen to
it not like this again yeah also another
weird thing is if you're buying any
reissued records of I never thought
about this but Marin made the point if
you're buying it likes a Guns and Roses
illusion records on vinyl those were
never mastered for vinyl because that
was after vinyl so that's a weird thing
to you know because unless they're going
in and remastering it from the two-inch
tape and cutting it to vinyl they're
just cutting it off the glass master and
he might as well just play the CD well
then it's the art right then one thing
and then maybe the scratch of the player
yeah that that air to it how many
records you got man over 100 yeah it's
easy to hear right ya know it really
moves and I find myself collecting music
all different types because I'll listen
from everything just everything you know
I've got like right in front of me I've
got about house like I said because I
just when I saw Peter Murphy life I like
Jessica Pratt she does acoustic folk
music you're into sad stuff like old
doors record store day I got doors live
at the Aquarius that's an incredible
record yeah that's an incredible record
that record right there they have able
to clear vinyl 180 gram innings oh yeah
yeah yeah and it and it has the sound
check small / 10 minutes a sound check
on like the second record obvious that's
odo that doors one and the doors live at
the matrix club in San Francisco are our
must owns oh really yeah yeah let's seek
that out and because of you like I
bought Lanigan on vinyl so good man
right that guy's good wow I got cheap
trick live in budokan record store day
yes the most famous record but at the
time they only released don't want a
single a single record now it's dual the
whole concert so I sat down and listened
to it yesterday and I was like this is
[ __ ] phenomenal you know I mean
phenomenal thank God for record store is
so cool you know now that you have a car
you can listen to CDs in your car so so
become so the car sold the car oh [ __ ]
already yeah and it did on the bike yeah
and it had a CD player which was
hilarious cuz Spicer was like look it's
got a CD player like um which by the way
spice I forgot to tell you got a bunch
of CDs for you but you're gonna sell you
want to say what do you why are you
giving me ya know these were like some
guy made me a mix of all kinds of great
[ __ ] of bands and everything anyway
thanks for calling in dude oh yeah no
pal and one last thing I just wanted to
get your opinion on this because you
mentioned nighties bands that you
rediscover it in your CD collection like
rooming yeah that was rising I i
disremember a grim got the stamp aroma
sample of approval from Johnny Ramone at
the time when they were getting hot I
guess and you know I just was thinking
like there's nothing that's going to be
as wild as Ramones lyrics again it seems
like you know because even though these
bands were approved by these these guys
from 70s just really seem like anybody
had that originality and kind of
craziness behind them but they're
standing out there it's just harder to
surface I was playing it for Dean
earlier visits band and they're not new
but I had not heard of them but they're
more like a hardcore punk called
turnstile and they have a song that if
when you hear it it you're like oh this
is rage against the machine yeah like
you could play this song for somebody in
Bakke oh [ __ ] new rage and there's stuff
like that two and not necessarily out of
socal anymore but it's weird because
music is everywhere I think it's easier
to find stuff it almost makes it harder
to find stuff if that makes that so
harder to be it's impossible original
yeah right there's got to be flavors of
originality like when I see the Yeah
Yeah yes I
worship Cara no thanks just one of the
top five front persons I've ever seen
but I get the flavors you know it's
missing persons it's blondie its Iggy
Pop I see it but when you when you can
roll it into your own thing that's
what's great if it's an identical
replica of something then you're [ __ ]
yeah I think why rival sons so great
yeah definitely and I think even though
the time of blondie or whatever I think
if you were in that era of music people
the only way you can describe something
is by describing it what it's like or
what it's not likely so you're like oh
yeah Elvis Elvis is great but he's kind
of like this black gospel group with
this little doo [ __ ] and this you know
that's how we compare and contrast thing
so it's hard to find originality without
having anything to compare to because
then I don't think your brain could
comprehend what you're hearing I like
when people say they sound like nobody
else come on man it's 2016 oh no no
nobody else was the band from 24 yeah
yeah man I appreciate the call dude
thank you for tuning in and kick ass man
oh and thank you very much and again as
far as 90s one last thing up sponge
about them if you haven't yet I know
buns quite well that's CD with that
weird dude on the cover with like
oranges on the fate or whatever it was
Ron kenyatta yeah it's a great record
it's a great record out I think I think
cloud is one of the best hard rock songs
ever and they had a lot of personality
do you know I saw them they're still
touring out of Detroit so it's amazing
like I put that Rooney CD on which by
the way it's available for streaming
which was cool I was like oh that's what
I started doing I started looking at all
these CDs I got this guy to be out of
print I'll selling on ebay it's rare
nope Tom [ __ ] even a streaming but
Rooney sense know people were going like
oh that's supposed to be the west coast
answer to the strokes there's nothing
like that there were way more like
jellyfish to me heavy Beatles harmonies
and a lot of diminished chords and stuff
but man they had two songs on that
record
being blue side and I forget the other
one but what a great [ __ ] record it's
got a an American bear on it if you're
looking for it on like a California
flagbearer but i think what hurt them
was they were all over that show the OC
yeah so that made it cheese you know
what I mean but I saw him live a couple
times in there were [ __ ] good if
you're singing and playing and doing
three part harmonies no one does that so
it's great to see ya alright man thanks
for offer taking the call again god
bless you guys yes yeah see you later
man a man who anyway so saying the final
is like a craftsman it's looked good it
sounded good people have enjoyed it for
whatever for forever and then a CD came
out and a CD is like that brick mansion
in the suburbs in like the 90s or like
90s rant or 70s ranch-style home when
it's built you're like oh these are so
great and then 10 years later you're
like yeah [ __ ] this yeah it's so funny
to think too i was talking to you about
how much money hard-earned money I spent
on those cds yeah and how disconnected i
was from him on friday yes it did there
was that no point as I go they're gone
yeah I was just more like and remember
what the guy said he goes looks like
you're doing a full blown Quincy yeah
they're on the place but uh do you
remember your first CD the first CD you
ever bought I you know cuz when they I
think it was the city to come on I think
it was too yeah because they were they
were so much money there were twenty
bucks the long cardboard so you couldn't
steal and I guess yeah and there was
only I said it over and over there's
only like 15 bands that were on CD yeah
you know like those like Eagles great
his hits but i think it was illusion too
i think i was boys to men and Janet
Jackson yeah like the same day and I was
like I had saved up for forever why was
I so much money growing it was hard 25
bucks i think yeah like it was real for
me is queen's greatest hits clean oh
that's [ __ ] what a great record yeah
it's so crazy to think
and the record company is doing the
exact [ __ ] thing they did back with
the city's came out there like oh this
is a whole new revenue everything else
is dead we're going to charge 25 for and
I just read a big story i think it was
in New York Times about that's what
they're doing with vinyl now and they're
killing these record stores because of
charging so much that the record store
has to charge like thirty dollars a
record yeah and then when people don't
buy them they've got this massive amount
of [ __ ] um like inventory yeah that
that's like you know of course we're
going to buy the classics right but
we're talking about all these bands that
are putting out vinyl now like let's say
Beyonce lemonade comes out on vinyl and
then they order like 5,000 of them and
then it's dead in a week because most
people steal music still yeah then
they've got a shelf full of these
Beyonce that no one's gonna buy cuz it's
not classic rights not going to be like
a doors record where people always want
that or even you know newer stuff like
strokes white stripes or to like you I
mean like that Beyonce album mites I
mean it is it's she reinvents or
something right I get it like maybe
that's a bad exhibit III soon yeah I'm
great album out right now on vinyl a
year from now is anyone going to be
looking for m83 junk I don't probably
not because it's kind of like a in
between album it's not like their
breakthrough album it's just this thing
but it's they're very hot band so I
would see a store or during a lot of
them like you said to now what what do
you do with that it's weird yeah it's a
tough coming a lot like movies where you
have to really sell the day it comes out
that's it it's all it's about now it's
it's like a cash grab hope they're
excited get it and and move on I really
like record store day because of people
bands really they there they take the
time to figure out what's going to be
super crazy rare and boom that [ __ ] is
gone I got the Grateful Dead live 77 New
Jersey I put it on
monday yesterday because we were gone
all week and it was there when I got
home and it was like wow this [ __ ]
thing is incredible and that cheap trick
incredible and the doors and the white
stripes that was released white stripes
has got to be one of the hottest vinyl
releases whenever it's out because Jack
White's a king of vinyl although [ __ ]
was great and they put out these peel
sessions that is insane gone instantly
you know do you think it's good that
things are released in that limited of a
quantity where is that pro-consumer
because they're kind of cheap bike
record store day's this is the time to
do it or does it just [ __ ] people
because then you have you know scalpers
that are get there at four in the
morning or hire people get their like
sneakers yeah like what is that line of
like you do it for the hard course and
not just hmm fall in the afternoon i
guess i'll go over your like you want to
be something to be excited about but at
the same time I don't want to spend
eight thousand dollars on ebay for the
White Stripes record or you know
whatever they're smart what they do is
they they release it on record store day
in like let's say that doors is in queer
vinyl yeah and boom there's 8,000 made
they're gone and about six months they
really sit but just in black with the
normal packaging and stuff so if you
really want the music and everything you
can still get it for like twenty bucks
and still you know so at least they
doing that right because you don't want
this you don't want the people yet doing
that like well you missed that because
then people start losing interest in
records like well [ __ ] I'm stealing it
again yeah I had to work and then it was
on sale and those kids in line like bill
comb and Josh Martin they stayed in line
all night yeah at amoeba so it was cool
to talk to him about what that was like
no I don't mind them doing it because
they're buying it for them it's like you
see the schlubby dude it looks like the
Simpsons comic book guy or whatever just
clearly like if you watch if you're not
in Hollywood if you're able to watch
like a red carpet event and you see it
looks like all these fans there may be
like 10 fans and then they're like a
million professional autograph seekers
like these just like gross looking dudes
at walls on my base
yeah as [ __ ] yeah I've been with
celebrities when we come out yeah from a
restaurant in this guy out there and
he's got like 40 items yeah and they're
like dude 2 item yeah tried a maximum
you know you're not a fan right yeah I
know what that is a [ __ ] weird thing
and I think I talked about it before on
here I never understood buying an
autograph I never said getting an
autograph I understand you're a fan I
got James Hetfield's autograph once and
I semi-new him from the day but there
was a point to me where I had the
laminate pass and it was New Year's Eve
they're playing Vegas he was sitting
there and I was like you know what it'd
be cool and signed this thing so later
on in life I was like yeah you know and
I asked him and he's like really yeah
you know it's like when I ask bir to
take a picture with him he's like really
yeah ah but I cheresh the moment you
know what I mean I as I was unpacking at
the new house there was years and years
and stuff I hadn't seen yesterday I
found a ticket stub from when i SAT Tom
Waits and t-bone Burnett do a special
benefit for their friend who went to
prison for selling acid he's doing life
yes he was arrested just it wasn't even
selling it it was just a sheet of acid
for him and his buddies back in the 70s
and the DEA would the way they did it
was they weighed the paper and you got
like 10 years / you know whatever
measurement some stupid [ __ ] thing
and the guys doing life in prison so
they did a benefit for him in 96 it was
one of the most in st. shows I've ever
seen it was at a healdsburg kind of elks
club thing yeah seated like maybe 150
Wow tickets were 196 a lot of [ __ ]
money but you got a poster and you were
three feet away from Tom Waits I found
that ticket stub yesterday as i was
still going through all the [ __ ] and i
was like wow and it just i sat down for
a minute was a shot a photo of it put it
on Instagram and and guys like oh yeah
I looked that up it was here that I was
like yeah man another thing to yesterday
I realized I had saw prints on the love
sexy tour oh [ __ ] i was watching DVF
YouTube clips yeah and I went [ __ ] i saw
that tour I've seen Prince so many times
I forgot my point is like i enjoy
collecting [ __ ] and i never understood
stuff where people bought something with
an autograph on it don't you think
that's weird I'm of two minds part of me
wholeheartedly agrees with you I think
it is weird but then part of me I see it
like buying the clearer doors vinyl
right because anyone let's say to do
reissue a black standard one and anyone
can have that and it's like anyone could
own a peyton manning jersey right anyone
go to whatever your sporting goods store
Dick's Sporting Goods and by that Jersey
but if you have the money to buy one
that online that he signed yeah it's a
little more limited because he hasn't
signed that conversation always goes
like this it's in a frame or in the
house and go WOW paint man in jersey
signed did you meet him and then this no
he mean conversation is over yeah
because the guy is up ready like how did
that happen what was he like where r uu
you yeah all that he's like nah ebay cuz
i'm a techie yeah and uh I get it I just
always tripped out on it you know it's
so bizarre now if you went to a mall and
paid for the guy to do it still cool you
mad at me now you can say whatever you
wanted to say like I remember Pete Rose
I told this story on somebody's my
husband I was in Vegas and I was doing
shows so I happen to be in the mall he
walked by I was like oh [ __ ] Pete Rose
yeah now Pete Rose is back from when I
like sports so immediately I want to
meet that guy say hey Pete Rose man
what's going on he's all hey I got hey
can I get a photo and he goes 25 I got
25 he goes I can't take a picture right
here because see that line and we were
going around attorney us they all paid
and I was like damn yeah not worth it
now worth it yeah yes and that's trying
to ninja yeah but let me answer my phone
real quick I mean I should have done it
actually just because Pete Rose is such
a gangster yeah I don't think I've ever
bought an autograph but at the same time
I think what I try to keep my head
pointed out is if it's someone else's
money and it makes them happy I get it
Who am I to judge this I'm not judging
you when I'm just saying I don't
understand it right because it's just
such a weird that thing of in a house
and it's autographed and then also is it
really him right always think about that
it's like when people buy used Rolexes
on ebay I'm like is that real in the
backyard mine it's always like it's not
a real autograph and they have a dumb
thing stupid certificate ah this is a
certificate saying this is an authentic
autograph and it's like that certificate
is about as authentic as that on a crap
you made both of them what if so to two
quick stories yeah first I have bought
one I just remember i said here's one i
was in middle school and we had like a
silent auction to benefit the school
yeah and i was in the bay area at the
time and they had this dope it was like
the mint or replica of the mint of the
cards used to press the upper deck I
think it was upper deck cards for the
Warriors that year and it was it was
signed and I was like oh [ __ ] I love
that's different I loved it and I was
like this is awesome and I was I think
sixth grade so I was a smart kid I could
read but I'd also never seen Chris
Mullins signature before yeah but I read
Chris and it was right by Chris Mullins
card yeah and I put all of my [ __ ]
allowance money in this thing and I want
it and I was so excited at the end of
the silent auction they read it out and
they were like and the signed warriors
plaque signed by Chris Gatlin and I was
like [ __ ] Chris gal wants Chris
Galanter Chris Gatlin and chris mullin
or like here and he said Christian was a
fine player but like but it ain't
flattop Mullen and no one rocking
redefining the game at the time
now yeah whitey from not on the ark yeah
that whole era and san fran i remember i
got a flat top somebody it was so bad it
was bird bird does jokes about you he'll
say something like you see that dick
with the 80s Terminator 2 flat top I
remember I went to this barbershop and
in san fran in the richmond district and
they had the poster you ever go to a
barber shop and they have the heads and
it it's like flat top with fenders duck
tail it's like from the 50 there where's
that picture on Instagram of that
haircut yeah and and the I know is early
on these dicks can't do these haircuts
and there's another thing about a
flattop you have a square head once you
have it it looked dope on Chris Mullin
right how dope did it look is great but
his was [ __ ] cool if you don't have
thick thick hair yeah to make it look
like a shape it's like if you tried to
do the gumby and you just had a bad you
know bad fro it wouldn't work you gotta
have killer hair could have fell so I
remember I got it I got home and I was
like god this is terrible and I had my
own shavers and I mean it was just like
me I just cut it off and then I couldn't
see in the back there's a patch i missed
Rose out that night my buddy's like it's
gonna hurt you got like a quarterback
here yeah there's just a quarterback did
chris mullin what are they called the
run run CMT or something they had the i
don't know it's like run DMC but they
had the guys you know yeah i just know
Nelly was coach oh so good they had that
bolt did i ever tell you the bolt story
no well you may be there the mascot was
the bolt yeah and I would go to the
Warner's games and that's back when like
no one was really there you know it's
kind of like early Giants game they were
good in that era they were like
first-round playoff loss Dallas area
after that though I'm saying that was
really good but right after they law at
team Blues Weber choked the [ __ ] out of
the coach and
err yeah and I think he went to the
Kings yeah but I would go and they had a
mascot called the bolt ugliest costume
August costume ever and and then the the
Warriors had the ugliest uniforms in the
middle of the arena the bolt everything
about it sucked and when they were good
we would have loved it yeah they weren't
good at like gonna be shitty and have
like the old bullets logo and be like
you hate so yeah but they're bad so I
used to rip on the boat all the time cuz
he'd be out there he would do tricks and
it shoots shirts into the stands and one
day when I started comedy like six years
ago my first year in I was hanging a lot
at the Laugh Factory and I was out front
and this guy was next to me and he did
comedy and I said hey man wait friend
micah's bearing on me too man he's all
yeah right on right we started talking
because you were into the Warriors
Golden State words and I got you know I
used to love a man and then they got
that bolt and it was just so [ __ ]
dumb I just couldn't take it and the guy
looked at me because I was the bowl and
I was get the [ __ ] out of here said
dickey-fuller OSHA comedian he was the
bolt down and I'm like what are the odds
i'm clownin the boat I could be the
worst mascot shitty outfitter it was him
he was the bowl and I [ __ ] couldn't
believe I was eating [ __ ] in front of
the ball I think he had to know his
outfit was shitty I still not I better
the guys we get it was just weird though
deluca Angus I was the ball and be like
[ __ ] on like a guy that was Bigfoot
at Universal Studios for years like that
[ __ ] dump guys I was Bigfoot yes I
mean what are the odds yeah the guy's a
comedian I meet him 20 years later i
love you siddiqui for anyway that's
great honey oh so then the second would
want to have balan okay second question
again just you personally but what about
like Babe Ruth well that's there's no
way you can get it right and it's on you
know
whatever I got an old Yankees hat yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's good but my in the
back of my head I'm always is this real
if I could see the chain of events yeah
he signs it for a dude you see the photo
The Dude's grandson selling its here and
still in my head I'm like maybe he had
like four minute a guy could [ __ ]
mimic it exact I'm always skeptical on
the signatures too and when you look at
our signatures you can google like say
babe ruth later on babe ruth was may be
drunk his signature was different mine
looks totally different from 10 years
ago I wasn't doing the same thing but
right not the same so it changes and now
you're like you know well this doesn't
look at all like that [ __ ] lose later
on babe you know and you're like I just
had to me I'm always kind of a skeptical
and and as you get older and believe me
I love I don't go signatures anymore I
go photo sure because I love photos and
it's an Instagram world of course and
and I read somewhere recently Kaname
yeah oh yeah i was reading we're on
there's great Norton Jim Norton
interview somewhere and the person's
breaking them down they said his insane
sexual habits his crazy new his diet and
his obsession with getting photos with
celebrities and and and I get that too
because I I it's not meeting the
celebrity it's if they inspired me in
life I'm so fired up like holy [ __ ] i
just met louie ck let's say you know
know my goddamn that's cool and i took a
photo with them and them it can be some
people try to play it cool like I'm in
the same biz I don't get hot for that
you know what I mean I don't believe in
that people inspire me and I and I and I
[ __ ] love what they do yeah I got a
photo with them Wow
I like it ya know yeah I'd opened for
Bowie last week by the way and I didn't
talk about it all week because I I did
the prince in a podcast and I I wanted
to be strictly about Prince and then
yesterday I didn't talk about it but I
own for Louie on Wednesday it was
absolutely the highlight of my life yeah
it is just when you see a man eight
years ago in a comedy club and he
[ __ ] absolutely makes you laugh your
head off and two years later you start
comedy because of that man and then six
and a half years later you're opening
for that guy yeah it's um it was it was
[ __ ] insane and it also helps the
fact that that guy is I mean arguably
everybody has a different list yeah but
the number one comedian working today I
mean it's gonna be a dope story if you
were like yeah and I saw sue at a comedy
club yeah and then she inspired me and
now here I am six years later opening
for sue sue ersten like hella cool story
but every was like who the [ __ ] is but
it's like it shows like the inspiration
the work ethic the climb the reward it's
a type of thing that like an aspiring
comic can look at and it can be the
reason why they get into it like this
[ __ ] can happen I mean it won't it can
happen well well by the way the Mount
Rushmore of comedy for me is you know
mayor am Aaron Burr seek a rock
Chappelle you know and and now I've
worked with all five yeah yeah I didn't
really work with Chris Rock in a way I
brought him up though when he was
popping in at the store and that was
[ __ ] crazy you know because of me
seeing him at the Paramount Theater and
only it was funny when I said this guy I
saw him 15 years ago and I was like I
want to do comedy and here i am doing
comedy and i'm bringing them up that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy and it's never
going to get old to me never because
those guys no matter what are the dudes
the reasons I love comedy yeah of course
I loved it when I was young sure but you
these are the guys that push me every
day to be better and and they're great
humans you know yeah to me I don't know
if I've ever said this before but my
well I still feel like a kid in a candy
store like there's great interviews with
Don Mattingly saying how much he still
loves the game of baseball and for me I
was like working comic when I when that
happens to me every show no matter what
show it is and then watching like big
name people do it to the thing that just
gets me giddy every single day is the
interaction between comics on stage when
they bring each other up yeah cuz
there's the set and the comic ends with
their clothes or whatever have a good
night and I ran in this next guy you
know you've got a great podcast called
let there be talk who's welcome to the
stage Dean Del Rey I kind of step away
from the Mike and let the audience you
know have their moment applauding you
come up and whether it's a handshake a
pound a couple of words or whatever i
love i love that interaction because
it's something that is so special
between you and that other comic even if
it's just uh you know yeah dab or
whatever that's the crazy one right
there yeah and I love watching it I love
watching like Judd Apatow bring up Sarah
Silverman I don't know what they say I
might just be like kill it yeah they're
not great but you see that you have a
moment there's a connection even if then
an open mic and the host brings you up I
always cherish that moment because it's
so unique to what we do yeah and so yeah
bringing up rock to me that's almost in
my I mess up there that'd be like the
most special thing it was insane when I
brought up bird I've told the story I
brought up burr again oh you fell over
all the [ __ ] he was giving me like dis
heaping praise on me then I knocked a
[ __ ] table over he just laid into me
for four minutes which is hysterical but
that moment I was a slight yeah this is
it and we say like two little words to
each other off mic and it's the [ __ ]
best I'll tell you the amazing thing a
lot of people were like man did Louie
like call and ask you to open up or
whatever and Louie doesn't do that you
know that would have been incredible if
he did but it meant more to me that Adam
at the store called me to open because
you're working and working and working
your ass off and you get to some brick
walls where you're just smashing into
the brick wall over and over and and you
say to yourself it does anybody see this
hard work going down
that's what you say to yourself over and
over and and that call from him and it
happened on wednesday at seven o'clock
the show was that know what's happened
at seven-thirty shows at eight thirty he
said where where are ya i said home and
he said how far are you from the store
and I said oh ten minutes can you can
you open for Lulu tonight and and in my
arm hair shot off my [ __ ] thing and I
said dude that's a dream of mine but you
said that in person you literally got
there so quick yeah like when I prove he
said how the [ __ ] you get yourself can I
go dude this is a I've been waitin to do
this since the day I did comedy and he
goes I mean you must have just thrown
your clothes on and got here and I go
yeah yeah I just laying in bed night and
seven thirty at night I threw my clothes
on he goes I can till your shirt's on
inside out and my shirt was inside out I
was like like God that's how [ __ ]
fired up I was and then I was just in
the parking lot walking back and forth
because I was like I can't believe this
is about to happen and I remember when
we pulled up and I went backstage I
didn't want to bother him yeah I was
getting ready to go on he came in and
shut up it was me Judd Apatow and Louie
it's great it's like wow and Jed was in
the dresser him I don't want to say a
word and I knew he was going over his
notes and I was looking at my [ __ ] what
I wanted to do is totally sold out and
then Louie came in and I said man you're
the reason I do comedy I wrote a
motorcycle here and I kept hoping i
didn't get run over on the way cuz i was
thinkin like he had it going on man it
was happening and then he got ran over
he's about to open from Lou I told that
story is laughing when I got off he said
a great job man yeah I mean wow you know
just be glad you had pants on Jeff might
like you're hauling ass over the hill oh
just notepad check out
it was a it was a great [ __ ] day man
yeah [ __ ] well uh what time is it man
we'll get out of here 319 yeah before we
do it I was going to talk about one
thing I'm gonna be in reno yeah um a
17th through the 22nd people keep asking
where it's at the Laugh Factory at the
silver legacy casino and then I will be
be headlining that for a week and then
I'm doing five nights in denver at the
Comedy Works five nights jun 28 through
july second if you live in Denver or
Boulder anyway please come out I love to
see you guys this is one of the most
prestigious rooms and it's the second
time I'm headlining it and I can love
the place we had a good time island was
great well in the crowds everybody there
was there's it was perfect it was it
really was perfect and like Coachella
was going on we had awesome [ __ ]
crowds like that didn't put a dent in
anything yeah man Comcast fans new fans
it was awesome and also shout out to
marry on scripts and and Sarah potatoes
yeah they came down to la jolla
connoisseur got hotel room yeah and came
to the shares man the show which is so
cool and also god I wish I remember his
name he came over from Tijuana oh yeah
it was great polisher to feel like a
dick I don't remember his name right now
oh wait I think I got it get it I want
to give him a shell I don't say thanks
to greg always Oh Greg a course on ad
from El Cajon Harley ball he brought
everyone from the dealer great and these
are like some serious great [ __ ]
friends yeah yeah which is really cool I
want to find this guy's name do I have
it got it that would suck of it which by
the way I just saw my things I'm still
trying to get Scott Ian from anthrax on
the podcast I'm still working on some
[ __ ] buddy oh I got Kai put in the work
today yeah anything else you know what
I'm talking about yeah yeah yeah that if
it doesn't happen you guys are better
off not knowing but
it happens to be gray yeah which by the
way i took a picture with I can't find
this guy's name I [ __ ] feel ball get
it was an impromptu yeah we'll get it
anyway I took a picture with josh homme
à from Queens yeah josh says he'll do
the podcast he's going to do it I said
future episode coming up and I can't
believe everyday people like when's dad
coming I mean believe me I wanted to
help as much as you guys do and I should
have saved the photo but once again I
was excited it's like holy [ __ ] josh
came to see burr and and i opened the
show and I was like dude you're your
dream guest and he really is I mean down
to talk about dream guest from Caius all
the way to I mean it's him it's Jack
White these kind of guys are dream guess
you know yeah alison mosshart which by
the way new kills record came out go get
that they destroyed a couple nights ago
at the Mayan wow what a great week of
music it's been Weezer played Harry the
troubadour Monday yeah [ __ ] I've it'll
come saw that yeah anyway what do you
got coming up oh I'm at the improv I
think on Saturday I don't know what else
this week this week's weird out of town
I'm in salt lake city may oh yeah 19th
20th whatever that weekend is that
thursday friday saturday i'll be in Salt
Lake City best way to see that is this
on my Twitter at Spicer and if you're a
parent and you like podcasts I have a
dumb what's not dumb it's a
light-hearted take on parenting
parenting podcast called Department of
parenting kick ass yeah and I will be at
the twinkle twins show Thursday night
which is tonight when this drops I drop
pitch ins on Thursday tonight nine
o'clock sharp Dana Gould me Kyle Kinane
Arden who else is on that Eddie Pepitone
about what a [ __ ] line up this is do
not miss that then saturday i'll be at
the comedy store with bill burr 1030 in
the original room and and sunday i will
be at The Comedy Store 9pm thank you
guys for tuning in keep leaving those
reviews and if you want to donate hit
patreon.com / Dean Del Rey
anything helps oh and you got a patriot
spy sir has a patreon if you want
nothing at all except just to roll your
window down and throw a couple bucks out
the window that's what spices patreon is
you get nothing it's not even a middle
finger no not a thank you so does a joke
I tweet it out I'm loyal I'm going on my
own subscription service to ninety-nine
a month and you get nothing no junk no
clutter like loot crate no shows you
need to binge watch Netflix nothing and
people this is hysterical and I was like
[ __ ] it I did it so if you go to
patreon.com/scishow yeah and donate to
ninety-nine a month yeah you will be an
official subscriber and you will get
nothing I will not tweet at you thank
you I will not send you anything you
will not get a shirt you will not get a
button you will not get it anything no
no TV show will be made yeah you'll get
[ __ ] all and if you do that if you
donate to them I will hate you because
I'm working my ass and if you skip mine
and good it is I'm like wow that's a
[ __ ] yeah all right let's get out
here thanks for tuning in guys see you
there I'm making like 4 grand a month